you know as far as retiring is concerned
I don't see that ever happening for me
I'll decide when I'm going to retire
right after I'm cremated
[Music]
my name is Bob Parsons I'm the CEO and
founder of yam worldwide and pxj
Harley-Davidson of Scottsdale yam
properties and on and on
there's always reasons to move on and
it's always reasons to stay I tend to
move on when it gets to the point where
I see a change in economics like for
example doing shrink wrap software and
the uh debut of the internet or with
GoDaddy where it's just got so many
moving parts so many things things going
on and so forth that
it's almost like managing a country my
job is to do all the early stuff get it
off the ground get it to where it is
making a big difference and and where it
is
well you know where where it it is
established and uh and it's obviously
viable and it's doing really well and
then when it gets to that point then
maybe it's time for me to uh
to uh move on
I went to the University of Baltimore
and they they had a a program for
veterans and so I I graduated with a
degree in accountancy uh magna [ __ ] laude
I took the CPA exam I passed it the
first time you know the Genesis of all
that was I was a
uh working as an accountant and I was a
controller with commercial credit
leasing Corporation in Baltimore so they
sent me to schedule out the assets of
this leasing company in Redwood City
California
and after I finished doing that this is
back in 75 after after I finished doing
that I um
uh had a 12 12 hour layover before my
flight back to Baltimore so I I found
myself on Stanford campus and went to
the bookstore and bought a book on
programming in the basic computer
language
and uh during The Layover I I read a
substantial part of that book and I also
wrote my first computer what would
become my first computer program
I started writing a program that would
do the family finances and uh over the
years it got good and uh I called it the
money eventually I called it money
counts and I I
tried selling that out of the basement
of my my uh house in my my first year
fifteen thousand I put in the business
and and I bought these small little ads
lost everything I might have sold three
copies and then the next year I wound up
I had close to 25
000 and uh did the same thing again kept
improving the software improving the
software and I lost all of that and the
third year
um
I just continued to work on the software
and then I got a call one day from these
people that worked at this magazine this
little rag you had a Fort Dodge Iowa
called uh the computer Bargain Line and
they had the front page the front page
uh that was uh
uh available somebody had bought it and
then dropped down I mean this is the
front page of the magazine right so they
said that it's normally like fifteen
twenty thousand something like that they
could sell it to me for five thousand
and uh would I be interested in it and
so I went ahead and said you got a deal
I had an ad made up and I could still
see it now it says money counts and I
dropped the price all the way to 12
bucks but it only cost twelve dollars
and back then software was copy
protected you had to use it like a book
you couldn't give it away this sort of
thing and what I said was it's not
coffee protected make as many copies as
you want give it to your friends do
whatever the hell you want just send me
12 bucks
and what happened was it ex sales
exploded I mean our mailbox with just
stuff full I mean I couldn't believe it
I would work 60 hours straight 60 hour
Clips in order to get this tax software
done and I would start let's say Monday
morning at eight o'clock I'd work
through Tuesday morning at eight o'clock
Wednesday morning at eight o'clock and
about eight o'clock at night that
Wednesday
I'd start the hallucinate or or hear
voices that weren't there I mean you
really need to sleep right and and I
just wouldn't be getting much done so
I'd go home
crash get up take a short little run
shower do it again
so I got the tax program done in late
January
and I think I made on the tax I made it
I made about 200 000. and I never made
that kind of money in my life and then
next year
selling uh tax software selling
Financial software I had a guy who wrote
Bible concordance lookup program so I
brought him into the pack and people
hearing the name Parsons technology
thought the company was founded to do
the Bible Software it was just the
opposite but any anyhow so that became
our church software Division and that
year I made five million no two and a
half million two and a half million the
next year I made five billion and then
in
94 decided to sell it we've seen the
Advent of the internet coming we were
doing shrink wrap software sold the
company to Intuit for 64 million dollars
I have
this here Department of the Navy
this was given to me in 2014
by the department of the Navy and it is
a
public service award for
supporting services that are providing
treatment for wounded and injured
veterans I think it's safe to say that
since I came home
everything I've ever accomplished Iota
the Marine Corps what the Marine Corps
taught me to taught me a number of
things
most important they taught me the
importance of responsibility and
honoring it and the importance of
discipline they also taught me that um
I could accomplish way more
than I ever thought I could
and that I had a right to be proud
this picture here was taken in the field
Hospital
the morning after I was wounded in
Vietnam and uh it's a colonel presenting
me with a purple heart
so uh what what we would do is we would
our task was to protect these little
Villages and we did that by setting up
ambushes at night so one of the things I
learned when I got there was that the
uh Squad have been ambushed my squad a
few days before I got there and they had
five serious casualties four of them
were fatals after I learned this I went
and um uh the place used to be old
French Fort there that was overrun could
be a movie set show holes in it and all
that sort of stuff so I sat on one of
the walls and looked out in the valley
and I remember thinking
how in the world am I going to survive
this I'm going to be here for 13 months
I don't know the first thing about being
in a bush here
the senior guy with my squad is there
six weeks
um
and the tour is 13 months so I mean uh
you know you know I just
seemed daunting to me then what turned
it around I just I'm sitting out there
looking out what a what a blank mind and
and then I just had this thought I'm
gonna die here this is where I'm gonna
die and
um
as soon as I accepted that I was at
peace it was like oh the stress left and
um
and I made myself two promises the first
promise was I do whatever I could uh to
do my job as a U.S combat Marine the
second thing was I wanted to be alive
from Malco in the morning so whatever I
could do I just want to live for mail
call and that's what got me through it
what got me through it was never looking
further than the next morning's mail
call
since I started Parsons technology I
haven't really started a company that
failed after I did the GoDaddy deal in
2011 I had a lot of cash and I I was
thinking you know it probably makes
sense to do something fun
and in I would say March or April of uh
2013. I went ahead and had the
opportunity to play the golf club
Scottsdale and um
I loved it I just loved it it was
surrounded by three million Acres of
government land in many cases was about
to have its own water uh did not have
houses built on the property anyhow I
wound up requiring that the you know the
golf club Scottsdale and renamed it
Scottsdale National and then I acquired
uh the property next to it was a big
Housing Development about to go in and I
acquired that and I built the second
course and then I built a little nine
hole course in a second Clubhouse and um
right now there's no other club in the
world like it
we are at hole number 11 on Scottsdale
National signature course it's called
the other course it was constructed over
one year
and um
uh the guys who did the Earth moving as
well as the Architects and and the
designers these were very talented
people and this looks like it's been
like this for a hundred years so what a
job they did I usually play two three
times a week
and if it's not sometimes I don't play
at all so it really just depends but I
love being here this is my happy place
Scottsdale National came slightly before
pxg
the same time I was at um
Scottsdale National when I when I first
bought it I had a guy come over and talk
to me and he goes you know if you ever
thought about starting a golf club
company you should talk to Mike
Nicolette who was one of the the chief
engineers at Bing I talked to Mike and I
said Mike I want a club that looks like
a blade but is performs a more forgiving
than a cavity back I wanted to launch
higher go further be more forgiving
than than than anything out there and I
wanted to look incredibly sexy and and I
wanted to feel as soft as butter when
you hit it so they went to work and we
had a number of false starts and we
finally settled during a hollow bodied
club with
that was in connected with a special
polymer that would absorb the impact
provide the oomph to get this thing a
little little you know further out there
more distance
it also was more forgiving it felt soft
as could be and because of the
proprietary way that we injected it and
what we use
we have developed the
thinnest face in golf
and that goal and that nobody's been
able to to emulate it
um and um that's our PhD clubs and they
are excellent we I believe we make the
best sticks money can buy right now we
have 16 stores by the end of the year we
should have 21 by the end of uh uh 2023
uh we'll have close to 40 if not more
stores afford us a place where our
customers can go and interact with the
brand as opposed to the internet as
opposed to you know a phone call and
they can walk into our store they can
feel and touch our products they can
talk to our employees and they can
interact with the brand and to me that's
incredibly important
[Music]
foreign
we're at one of our our build shops we
call whiskey and whiskey is the
military alphabet name
for the letter w
that's why we call it Whiskey what they
do is they look at the clubs that need
to be built and they build them we work
in pods and we found that that's one of
the more efficient ways
and um everything's done on a team basis
just like the Marine Corps you might
look at these pods as our squads
and a group of PODS of Platoon
and a group of platoons
company
I grew up in East Baltimore
which was a lower class Blue Collar
neighborhood I wasn't a very good
student if I was a kid in school today
I'd be pumped full Ritalin
this paper here
comes from I think I was in the second
grade the teacher got together with my
mother and says what do I have to do to
get little little Bobby's attention and
um so the concocted this plan where each
day I would bring my papers home and my
mother would sign them and this is the
paper that I brought home on day one
you can see it says here from the
teacher where is your work zero work all
right and um my mother saved it and when
I opened my first office with my first
business first startup parts of
Technology she framed it and gave it to
me
and she says just remember where you
came from
I tell you every year whether I passed
or failed was a was a photo finish and I
actually did fail the fifth grade though
what happened that Year sister Brenda
which was was my teacher she told gave
everybody their report cards told them
what a wonderful job they did and then
they had me Frankie and Anthony sitting
in her chairs and told it didn't give us
report card said you guys stay here and
I'm going to take the line out and then
I'll be back to take care of you guys
and I knew that meant we failed so at
that point I mostly wanted just a nun
free summer and as soon as she left
I left the school never called
it was the longest summer of my life so
I got to the to the first day of school
for the new year had all my new school
stuff and I got in the sixth grade line
so the bell rings
and uh you know the lines start going in
kindergarten first grade second grade
and uh gets up to sixth grade and I'm
about the last guy in line and sister St
Thomas she pulls me out of line put me
up against the wall and her nose must
have been this far from my face and she
said to me
sister Brenda told me what you did
she told me that uh you failed but you
didn't wait around for her to process it
that you went ahead and left uh
she didn't know what to do
so she passed you
I mean it was one of the best things
I've ever heard you know I graduated
from high school I thought I was going
to fail most of my classes and so I had
two friends of mine Charlie Mason and
Niggy sirokis after gym class one day
they came to me and they said well we're
going to go down and talk to the Marine
Corps recruiter when I got my orders I
showed all my teachers a number of my
teachers when I showed them I ordered
they cried
um and they all passed me
and then so we spent the summer knocking
around in August uh we went to um
uh Parris Island for boot camp went over
to um
Vietnam when I got back from Vietnam I
was a different guy
and I was a different guy in good ways
and not so good ways I came home with uh
flash temper
I
I was often described as the most
intense person anyone has ever worked
with I mean I was one focused dude I
gotta tell you and I
be by myself
start thinking about the war cry
that sort of thing
and uh
I can tell you
PTSD makes for a life that's much harder
than it should be and it's not only for
the for the veteran he or she it's also
for their family
you know I've I've often said that um
one of my true regrets is that
you know when when I came back I was a
worker bee I mean I
I put in some hours
and uh that continued long
but um
one of my regrets has always been that I
wasn't around my kids as much as I would
have liked to be
but given the PTSD and how I was then
probably a good thing I wasn't around
and
you know I got my PTSD was pretty
manageable now I have a good
relationship with each one of them the
one thing about about PTSD to understand
that how how it is is understand how I
am after I've had it treated I talked to
my wife about the
PTSD and and um
what I'd like to do to
get rid of it I mean it just to get back
to the way I was and I told her I'd like
to try psychotage because I've never
done anything like that
um and and uh so
she had me she hooked had me hooked up
with two people that treat vets under
the radar within two weeks
and I met with them later that year in
August in Hawaii started doing it on the
first day I took ayahuasca
and um
I I didn't um
didn't hallucinate but I could tell and
what the psychedelics do the
psychedelics is make the person that's
being treated receptive to the treatment
it makes them willing to make changes
open to make changes and more open to
talk about and reliving the experiences
that got them there
so Ayahuasca did that for me on the
second day I took
magic mushrooms
and my guide told me he said I made a
teapot of of tea with these magic
mushrooms with psilocybin and I made it
really strong it holds three cups you'll
only need one cup
well I drank all three cups
and I ate the tea bags
the guy said I've never seen anything
like this before
and did I hallucinate no but um was I
lit I'd say righteously and um
of course and we stepped through it more
and it's painful and tears and
they're getting treated with
psychedelics is not a happy thing
because you're going to relive
you're going to relive what's uh what's
causing the problems but that's the only
way to get it out in the open and to
treat it and the fourth day rather was
LSD and
um
I can tell you the the whole treatment
was um
was painful
but it was so worth doing and
um
afterwards
people could not
they they were Amazed by the change in
me
I said what what happened to him he's so
nice he's so easy going he has no temper
it had been
49 years since the war
I finally came home
this is when I was the guest of honor
for the Marine Corps evening parade at
eighth and I barracks
you know I do a lot of public speaking
and one of the things I get asked time
and again is what in my life am I the
most proud of and it's a very easy
question
I am a United States Marine you got to
love what you're doing because when you
love something you're willing to work
harder at it spend more time at it just
for the sake of doing it right and um
when you you're competing against
somebody who's doing whatever they're
doing
and they're doing it just to make a
dollar
you got them
in all three cases
I just I did those businesses because I
wanted to make a difference
and I wanted to do a job that nobody's
done before if you're doing it because
you want to make a difference there's
things you have to do to get a business
off the ground and working and to create
enthusiasm that if you look at from a p
l standpoint make no sense it just does
not make sense but if you look at it
from the standpoint of creating
enthusiasm and and and doing something
incredibly healthy for the you know to
to bring the customer closer to your
business makes all the sense in the
world when you're doing that you're
thinking the right way and when you
think the right way you have a big
chance of succeeding and when you're
thinking the wrong way you're dead in
the water my life is I got a lot of
people that depend on me both you know
who are recipients from the things we do
with our philanthropic arm to our
employees to just other the people we
deal with that keeps me going and one of
the things I believe that you know
everything moves on
and so I don't worry too much about a
legacy or or that sort of thing I just
um
I want to do the best that I can and I
want to do right by the people I come in
contact with you know for a while at
least you know when the day comes when I
move on to whatever the next life holds
right I don't think about me at least
for a while and that's enough
[Music]